so I am the guy who was sad over there
for the last four weeks he now has the
pleasure of talking to you about what I
do some assistant professor here the
Child Study Center and I'm the associate
director of the developmental
electrophysiology laboratory which is
run by Linda Mays and we kind of pool
our resources comple-- all apply the
same methods to study child development
both typical and atypical development
and we also all are kind of interested
in Social Development for different
kinds of reasons I should also
acknowledge Michael Crowley who's the
other associate director of the del Sol
when we start a talk like this in the
medical school we make disclosure we
present everything that gives us a bias
so there's the financial biases these
are the people who fund the research
that we do so I get money to do my
research from a couple of different
government institutes and I will soon
from NAR sad and then I also get money
for book sales and then in this
particular instance I want to disclose a
non-financial
conflict of interest because we all the
presenters you've heard us kind of grave
about this it's weird for us what we do
as clinical psychologists is show lots
of pictures of people and we show you
videos of people and they make things
interesting they keep the people who are
listening to awake which is something
that we all like we can't do that for
this but for me it's a different
situation because every moment that I am
speaking to an audience and showing them
pictures of people who are not my
children I am experiencing an internal
tension so now I have the nice
circumstance where I have only the
choice to show you pictures of people
whose right to consent I control and so
you'll be seeing lots of Nora and Agnes
in the next hour or so so what I'm going
to talk about today is the research that
I have been doing here I've been here
since 2004 I first came here as a as a
clinical intern I'm a clinical
psychologist and then I did a postdoc
and then I've been on the research
faculty and then the regular faculty
since then so I am very interested in
autism and the way people with autism
process information and because I think
of autism
as a social disorder I'm very interested
in the way they process social
information and one of the best ways to
study social information processing is
with faces so we're gonna start off
talking some about behavioral and brain
specialization for faces and then I'm
going to talk a little bit about
electrophysiology about the method of
electrophysiology because it's not
familiar to everybody and some of the
things about it or a little
idiosyncratic I'm going to talk about
face perception as a tool to understand
autism and social development in autism
and whether the problems that we see in
autism are better explained as a general
information processing problem or some
kind of specific problem like a specific
problem to social information and then
I'm going to talk about some of the work
that's going on now and some of the
things that we have in store and please
do interrupt just because the cameras
are rolling doesn't mean that you can't
ask questions so please do I maybe I'll
try to be unclear so you have to ask
questions so when we think about autism
and this should all be familiar to you
now we think about autism as problems in
three areas
so social problems problems with
communication and that can be lots of
different kinds of problems
communication it could mean that you
just don't talk it could mean that you
have lots of language but have problems
communicating with people but mostly
resolving revolving around social
communication and then a third category
that's a lot more nebulous and less well
defined and we describe this as rigid
repetitive behaviors and interests and
this could be anything ranging from
repetitive motor movements like hand
flapping or being really insistent on a
particular schedule or pick a particular
routine so those kinds of things so and
when we have problems in all of those
areas we describe them as autism
spectrum disorders one of the things
that's really crucial to think about
when you think about autism is that it
happens in a developing child so autism
isn't just something that happens right
it's something that a person is most
likely born with but then they carry
that through them through carry that
with them
as they they move through the world and
in that respect
autism shapes the world a person lives
in so whatever is different about their
brain when they're born it's also
affected by a very different world that
they live in so there's the kind of
primary things that first shape the
brain but in there's a secondary things
that a person experiences as they move
through the world as a person with
autism so if we think about typical
social development kind of representing
this course so we come into the world
really attuned to people and I'm going
to talk about I know you all are gonna
have a face face development overload
because Kasia talked about some of it
already but I'll try to talk about some
of the facts that she she didn't touch
upon because these are some of the
things that I think are really coolest
about human development but I'll talk
about we cut how we come into the world
really paying close attention to people
and we remain that way for most of us
people are really what makes the world
go around and we spend our lives
thinking and learning about people it
become social experts but we can think
about people a lot of people with autism
for example charting a different course
so kind of becoming expert in other
things so paying attention to things
besides people learning about those
things becoming experts in other things
what's important to think about about
this kind of way of understanding autism
it's that we're not saying that this is
a brain that can't do certain kinds of
things
we're saying it's a brain that's paying
attention to the wrong kinds of
information which is a crucial
distinction when we think about the
different kinds of theories that people
have put forward to explain autism they
can kind of grossly fall into two
categories the idea that there's
something wrong with social information
processing or the idea that this is a
brain that can't handle the nature of
processing of things that happen to be
social and by that I mean for example
complex information the idea that people
who autism only have trouble with social
information because it's complex versus
there's being something uniquely social
about it and so we look at it this way
we're saying this is a brain
that can do many sophisticated many
complex things just can't do them with
social information and so as a person
who's interested in development when we
look at these these pathways right we
think of this a person getting older as
they move along and we want to
understand how we can trace it further
back right if we think about this person
the further they get down here the
harder time they're having with many of
the things that really matter in the
world cuz a lot of the things right now
that matter in the world from having
friends to to checking out of a
supermarket involve people and so one of
the ways we study this is with faces
because we can learn so much about faces
very early in life and we can apply it
throughout a lifespan so it's a good way
for us as people interested in child
development to try to get down to the
brass tacks in terms of where things
start both in healthy social development
and in terms of where things go awry in
a typical social development so let's
talk some about faces in typical social
development so we know that faces are
probably the first way I guess sound to
some of my colleagues have lots of
interesting theories about the way sound
could shape social development even
within the womb but conventionally faces
are one of the first ways that we learn
to interact with other people that we
learn about other people and we also
know a lot about faces so developmental
psychologists cognitive neuroscientists
neurologists have all done a lot of
great research to help us understand the
way people approach faces both in early
infancy and throughout the lifespan so
it's a really nice comparison for autism
which is we think of something has to do
with social social interaction that we
think affects us very early in life and
that we think Carius carries through the
lifespan but then we know very little
about in terms of the neural basis and
so faces are a nice way to kind of tap
in to those areas that are have yet to
be explained in autism so just some of
that I guess I'm William Kumpf axe we
can call them factoids about faces
unless you instead
very early in life so infants 9 minutes
old are more likely to look at faces or
things that are even things that are
just like faces so if you take a
schematic face just with two squares on
the top and one square on the bottom
kind of like two eyes and a mouth but
not even the right shape just the
configuration infants are gonna look at
that more than other things they're
gonna track it further so if you move
one across an infant's field of vision
they're gonna follow it further and this
is compared to even an upside-down one
or a bull's eye you can take lots of
things that you might be interesting
that you might think would be
interesting to infants all the
fisher-price toys oh we have to take
that out of the you tube cut all the
fisher-price toys in in Toys R Us are
not as interesting to most infants as as
faces we also know that babies are more
likely to smile at human faces this is
my older daughter doing her best pirate
impression as a five week old we know
that uh that again infants seem to enjoy
looking at faces which is a great tool
so how many people in this room have
ever interacted with a really small baby
you say a five week old baby so if you
do something to that baby and that baby
smiles at you what do you do I'm sorry
you smile back you do it again right
I've spent over the past three years
tremendous amounts of time making stupid
faces and stupid sounds to make this
happen again and so here is this little
helpless baby that has is one tool they
can use that can then control the
behavior of an adult very effectively
right so what a great way to to draw the
kind of information that we need to
develop right if people talking to us
and smiling at us and making silly
sounds it's what's going to help us grow
it's pretty amazing that human infants
come into the world able to elicit that
information from their environment so by
the second day very young children are
able to recognize the face of their
mother and these have been very elegant
studies controlling for whether a person
has also just given birth so it's not
new mother Ness
there
amazing it's not the scent of their
mother they're recognizing it's not her
blondness who burn her brunette Nisour
her blue-eyed miss they're recognizing
the face of their mother by the second
day of life and in one of my my favorite
studies of all time this is a study done
by Andy meltzoff who is at the
University of Washington who was
fortunate to study with as a graduate
student and what Andy did was he
partnered with a maternity ward in a
hospital in Seattle and he found some
parents who were apparently very very
motivated to help science and they got
his beeper number
and when the baby was born and he was
beat and whether it was noon or whether
it was midnight or whether it was 3 a.m.
or 9 a.m. and he would zip down to the
hospital and that newborn baby would be
put in a baby carrier and Andy would
hover over the baby with a video camera
behind him filming the baby but not
filming Andy and then Andy would do
things to the baby he would stick out
his tongue he would pucker his lips he
would open his mouth all while the video
camera was recording the baby so then he
would take these videotapes back to his
research assistants and they would code
what the baby's face was doing and sure
enough you were able to predict what
face Andy had been making by looking at
the baby so the youngest kids that they
saw this happening and we're kids who
were 42 minutes old so what's so
remarkable about this is that when we
think about the kind of the cliche of
nature versus nurture right there hasn't
been a lot of nurturing that's happened
in 42 minutes all right so these are
kids who haven't had a ton of time to
learn about their own face they haven't
had a ton of time to learn about other
people's faces and yet they're able to
see what's happening there
understand what's what that is what's
there is what I've got here and what
that is doing I can do and Andy really
takes this as the the basis for all
social interaction the idea he calls the
like me hypothesis the idea that
children are born with a with an
internal and intramodal and
intramodal map so that they can kind of
map on what they see to their sense of
their body and he thinks that that's
from where social interaction emerges so
then we also know that we theorize that
face processing also gives us a
foundation for much more sophisticated
social interaction skills so does
everybody know what theory of mind is
who can tell me what period mind is
exactly right that other people have
their own intentions their own wants
their own needs their own beliefs
and so one of the ideas for the
development of a theory of mine and
Simon baron-cohen who's a very
productive autism researcher has written
eloquently about this is that under
understanding other people's faces and
understanding other people's eyes is the
first way we can learn about other
people's intentions and by understanding
other people's intentions we can then
build the idea that their intentions
aren't necessarily the same as ours and
that's the basis of a theory of mind so
we've talked about these kind of early
these aspects of early development that
are really precocious we're very good
with faces before we're very good with
many other things and as we develop we
see that the human brain has special
ways of handling faces and this is
evident through two lines of evidence
one line of evidence is processing
strategies so behavioral studies that
I'll talk about show us that we seem to
handle the information in a face
differently than we handle most other
kinds of information and then also brain
studies through through autopsies
through intracranial recordings through
fMRI and through electrophysiological
studies on the outside of the scalp we
also find their special brain regions to
handle faces in terms of processing
strategies two things that are really
robust findings in faces are the
inversion effect in the decomposition
effect so the inversion effect is really
simple when we turn a face upside down
it's much harder to recognize we're all
very good at recognizing faces and it's
pretty remarkable when you think about
it right so here's a room full of people
and you all look completely distinct to
me but it but you also all have two eyes
a nose and a mouth I apologize if I'm
mistaken about anyone I'm assuming but
you you all have this same set of
features on your face right we all are
kind of the same and yet we look totally
different if you think about carrots or
apples right we're monkeys
we have monkey researchers in the room I
have tried I've done experiments where I
use monkey faces monkey faces are at
least as variable as ours
right they've got different hairs it
might even make it a better clue about
telling monkeys apart but I can't tell
them apart right we're really good at
telling apart these things these faces
that are all pretty similar but we turn
them upside down and we're not much
better at telling them apart than any of
anything else then there's also a
finding called a decomposition effect so
even though we can know people's faces
very well we're very bad at recognizing
facial features outside of the context
of the face so even though this is my
younger daughter Aggie so even though I
recognize her face very well you know
taking her eyes or her nose and putting
them outside the context of her face
with another baby's nose or eyes I'm not
gonna do nearly as well as I would with
the entire face and so what these kinds
of findings the idea that faces upside
down or faces and pieces are much harder
to process it tells us that we might be
encoding the information in the face in
a different way so we think that most
objects we encode in a piecemeal way so
kind of the idea that a monkey face or
an apple or a carrot is really just the
sum of its parts but a human face isn't
a human face is encoded as a whole using
configural processing strategy so we
learn faces as a unit by recognizing
their features with respect to one
another so the idea is it's a really
distinct processing strategy that we
apply selectively to human faces and
that we we learn to use over time as we
become experts in faces we start to
apply this processing strategy we also
know that we have special parts of the
brain to process faces and the first
evidence for this came from the work of
a neurologist and he found patients who
could lose the ability to recognize
individual faces while still being fine
at recognizing other things so if they
go to get their keys they're not gonna
pick up their co-workers keys but if
they go to pick up their wife they might
pick up their co-workers wife so he
he looked at the brains of these people
and he found that almost without
variation this disorder was secondary to
damage to certain parts of the cortex
part of the infertile temporal cortex
and most of the time it was on the right
sometimes it could be on both but most
the time this was on the right and so
this was the first clue okay so maybe if
people who get this part of the brain
damaged lose this skill maybe this part
of the brain has something to do with
the application of this skill and so now
we have a lot more elegant ways to look
at the brains and you'll hear I believe
next week from my colleague Kevin
Pelphrey who applies the method that
it's named on the slide functional
magnetic resonance imaging and what
functional magnetic resonance imaging
done or effort does or fMRI is lets us
look at blood flow within the brain so
it tells us when we have a person
performing a task inside an fMRI magnet
we have a good sense of - where in their
brain blood is flowing and that gives a
very good sense of the spatial
resolution of activity so where in the
brain things happen so in 1997 a paper
was published a very famous paper a
seminal work the third author of the
paper some of you may recognize he is
now a faculty member in the Department
of Psychology Marvin Chun and if I was
allowed to show copyrighted information
you would see a picture of Marvin from
that Journal article with a little
fusiform gyrus lighting up right next to
him but we can't so we'll just say so
instead is another excuse to put a
picture of my daughter there she is
modeling a neuroscientist and training
t-shirt from a mentor of mine at Harvard
Chuck Nelson who has done a lot of
pioneering work in in understanding
infant brain activity using ERP so what
they found using fMRI is that when you
show people faces compared to many many
things animal faces places hands you saw
this part of the brain selectively
activated since part of the brain called
the fusiform gyrus which they called the
fusiform face area there's a more
nuanced story
than just the fusiform face area that
I'll get into in a little bit but now
let's talk a little bit about
electrophysiology I think that
electrophysiology is a little bit more
mysterious than some of the other
methods that we use to study to study
brains and to look at people's behavior
and things like that
so when we talk about electrophysiology
we often talk about ERP so ERP stands
for event related potential have you all
heard of EEG before so maybe you've
heard about it because EEG s are used
clinically so EEG is
electroencephalogram and that's just a
recording of the electrical activity
that your brain produces so all the time
when we're doing anything as long as
we're alive
our brains are producing a small amount
of electricity and it's noisy lots of
different things are happening in that
electricity if I just show you a face
and look at the electricity that your
brain is making it's going to be kind of
confusing and if I show you a second
face it might not look exactly like what
we saw in response to the first face but
what we can do is if we show you many
many faces eventually what is the
electrical activity that is elicited
specifically by that face is gonna kind
of emerge from the noise right so if I
do the same thing many times sixty times
a hundred times eventually if I collapse
all of those trials together and I
average them I'm gonna get a decent
enough signal-to-noise ratio that I will
see the electrical truth I'll see the
activity that is happening in response
to this discrete event that's happening
that is related to this event this event
related potential ERPs
don't reflect the referring the firing
of a single neuron they reflect the
friary of many many neurons that are
firing in synchrony so it really gives
us a window in a particular kind of
brain activity the nice thing about ERPs
is their timing so I stressed before
with fMRI that we get a very good sense
of
we're in the brain things happen with
ERP we don't I think about ERP s almost
like shadows electrical shadows on the
scalp and so you know that a shadow has
been cast and you can show two different
kinds of images and see whether the
shadows are the same or different but
you really don't know exactly where the
light source is creating that shadow or
what exactly the size of the object
creating that shadow is so we have a
very difficult time knowing exactly
where in the brain ERPs come from but we
can really pinpoint in a way that we
can't with other neuroimaging methods
but timing so ERPs give us millisecond
resolution to understand differences in
cognitive events in the brain so the the
resolution of ERP parallels the
resolution of actual brain processes so
we can get a sense of things like the
timing of a response that we can't get
from other methods and what I say that
we we can't really tell where and the
brain things are coming from with ERP
that's kind of a debated point and
that's certainly the conservative stance
to take as an ERP research or maybe I
should come out kind of fighting a
little bit and take a more aggressive
stance because what we can do is a
process called source localization so if
I have many many points data points on
the scalp and I can measure the
electrical activity at all of them
I can cut test hypotheses I can say well
if I see a pattern of activity that's
happening response to a face I know
forever MRI studies do these form gyrus
is involved in faces so what I can kind
of create a seed net fusiform gyrus and
see if electricity electrical activity
propagating from there could potentially
result in the pattern of activity I see
on the scalp so we can do that and
that's called source localization
analysis and I'll actually show you an
example of that later today the problem
is is the inverse problem and the
inverse problem is really simply that
for any given because there could be
more than one source of electrical
activity in the brain for any given
scalp distribution there could be an
infinite number of potential solutions
inside the brain so we can get a sense
of where things come from with with ERP
where things come from in the brain but
it's really not
as robust as fMRI and really we're
increasingly starting to think about
them as complementary tools now we have
the technology to be able to record erps
inside fMRI magnets so that we can look
at both the timing and and the places in
the brain where things happen so what
does an ERP look like so this is a
geodesic sensor net I'm gonna give lots
of attention to the creators of this net
because I'm using pictures from their
website so this is electrical geodesic
the director Don Tucker is a close
collaborator of ours
this is actually an outdated version
this was a picture they sent me several
years ago but basically the idea is you
have many electrodes this is a 256
electrode net and so you see you could
all those white things that you see are
plastic pedestals inside each one of
those plastic pedestals and you can kind
of see it right there is a small sponge
inside that sponge is a small electrical
sensor which is connected by all of
these wires to an amplifier to boost a
signal because it's a really small
signal that's why we don't shock each
other and then that amplifier feeds to a
computer that records the brain activity
the reason who can guess maybe it's not
a guess if you've been involved with EEG
why would we want to have sponges in
there and I'll give you a clue why don't
you wait in the surf during a lightning
storm
exactly right and what kind of water
best conducts electricity I'll give you
another we might we would wait in a lake
before we waited in the ocean in a
lightning storm so we actually so we
soaked all of these sponges in an
electrolyte solution it's actually
potassium chloride not sodium chloride
and that helps pick up the electricity
from the scalp so this is a really nice
technology there's different ways to
record EEG there's the traditional way
is to kind of scratch the scalp a little
bit with like a needle and use a an
abrasive gel that kind of creates a
contact but this is a really nice
solution especially if you're working
with babies or as maybe anybody familiar
of a with a developmental disability
sometimes associated with sensory
sensitivities like throughout like let's
say hypothetically you're sitting in a
class about autism right so it's a nicer
solution for working with you with
autism because a little bit easier to
tolerate than scratching someone's scalp
and using the gel based the way you
apply it is you just kind of stretch it
over a person's head and here's a
close-up of what those electrodes look
like and this is from the newer version
from what we call a hydro cell net which
just have smaller sponges sponges
imbedded in little cups that actually
help things not dry out so fast so you
can any longer experiments so which any
questions about the technique or this
hat or any of this stuff or any
questions about anything I've talked
about so far
well the Hat you mean how do they do
have experiment it's a really good
question
well enter and let me compound your
question with a question
professor McPartland how do they do it
when infants have such poor visual
acuity and the answer is they probably
do with configuration so infants see low
spatial frequencies better so they're
going to kind of see the dark spots and
so that's seem remarkable right it's not
like they're saying oh yeah my mom is
the one with the really salient crow's
feet know they're recognizing my mom's
the one with this configuration of eyes
nose and mouth
it's a good question we couldn't be sure
right my guess would be and this is
coming both less from being a cognitive
neuroscientist child psychologist person
who studies human development and more
from a father is that when a baby is
born and you put them to the breast
nurse or even if you don't breastfeed if
you give them a bottle that infant gaze
is so intently at a person's face that
that's probably how and it's really I
don't I don't know the different
theories about what example exactly
happens is happening in the brains of
babies in the moments when they're born
but little babies are can be quite worn
during but they're generally pretty
peaceful is this period of kind of they
call it up what a wakeful alertness so
right after infants are born when they
kind of look at everything and take
everything in so who knows maybe there
but it's a good question but it's not
it's not known we could look at it I
mean we can use ERPs on very very early
babies so who knows I mean you could
look at response to what's hat what's
happening well I guess I'd be pretty
hard to look at because we need multiple
trials but we could record the response
rate but it could also be some kind of
pairing right so even though infants
seeing his or her mother's face for the
very first time they've been hearing the
voice for a long time right and so maybe
it's hearing seeing this come with this
familiar voice it's good question any
other questions I'm so happy we got a
question right mid lecture this is a
banner day for psychology 350 any other
questions okay so the nice thing about
ERPs
is really all you have to be able to do
is to be able tolerate wearing a hat so
we can put this hat on very very young
babies infants children adults when
working with people with autism we can
put this hat on people with autism who
were much much smarter than anybody in
this room we can also put this in people
with autism who don't have any language
or who have ostensible cognitive
impairments so it really gives us a it's
widely applicable in terms of studying
brain function
so when we think about the way we do an
ERP is we have a person wear this hat
they sit in a chair in front of a TV
monitor it doesn't have to be a TV
monitor we you could also do erps to
auditory stimuli in fact people have
actually to try to so I'll talk about
face perception today and all the faces
I show you are they're not real faces
they're pictures of faces on a computer
screen so people have reason well how
can we be sure the people will treat the
face on a computer screen the same way
as a regular face we've actually done
experiments where they have a person
behind what's the club piezo electric
piece of glass so when you turn charge
you can make the glass opaque or
transparent and so we've actually done
ER piece to real faces but here we do
ERPs two two pictures on a computer
screen you make the same thing happen
many many many times one thing that's
really important about ERPs
is making sure that you have some
measure of a person's attention because
what if you know I do a study of face
processing in people with autism and
typically developing peers and I see
differences but one of the people with
autism we're all looking out the window
during the course of the experiment
right that could be the reason for their
different brain activity so it's very
important you have some kind of measure
that a person is paying attention and so
these are these are images taken from
the website of the Locke lab led by
Stephen Locke who's really one of the
pioneers of er pinyin if any of you are
interested in reading more about the
basis of ERP I'd be happy to lend you
his very excellent introductory books
what you can see is you have so the
ongoing EEG and then we have things that
happen so if you see here this is the
first let's say you know he just calls
it stimulus but let's say it's the first
face and then we see a response and then
the second face and then we see a
response and then so on to the enth face
and we see lots of different responses
and then what we can do is take all of
those responses and average them
together so if you see this one this one
this one they have some commonalities
right for all of them there's some kind
of dip here there's something else over
here and there's something else over
here
but when we average them all the
different kinds of pieces of noise
because lots of things are happening you
might be blinking you might be
scratching your leg you might be
thinking about your homework assignments
or what you're gonna do this weekend but
you're not gonna be doing all of those
things in perfect synchrony with the
presentation of the face each time and
so when we only look at the activity
that's in perfect synchrony with the
face we eventually get an ERP waveform
which looks like this so it's a little
bit smoother and yet it preserves the
kind of features of each individual
trial when we think about ERP users this
is the the most basic way to analyze
them there's now more sophisticated ways
using multivariate statistics that I'm
not going to talk about today but we can
think about ERP components and an ERP
component is really just a feature of an
ERP waveform that we reason to be linked
to some kind of cognitive event and the
two aspects of an ERP component that we
pay attention to are the amplitude which
is usually expressed in microvolts and
that's shown by that purple arrow there
and the latency which is expressed in
milliseconds and that's shown by that
that green arrow there so this would be
a component and we would talk about its
amplitude is how far down it's going and
it's latency is when it Peaks when we
talk about ERP components the way we
refer to them is usually with a
combination of one letter and a number
or series of numbers and there are for
certain exceptions to this rule but
generally speaking we talk about things
being an or P and meaning it's a
negative going electrical component P
meaning it's a positive electrical going
component and then we could call it
either and like an n1 or an end to
reflects an ordinal value so an n1 would
be the first negative peak in the
waveform and two would be the second
negative peak in the waveform we can
also refer to it specifically with the
timing of the peak and that would be for
example we'll talk about today and n170
so an n170 would be a component that
goes positive or negative
it's fun this is an easy one guys that's
right-
and what would be the latency of the
n170 and i said so is it and is 170
milliseconds fast or slow that's fast
hundred seventy milliseconds is not a
long time right so that's one of the
neat things about erp and that's one of
the reasons we're going to talk about
the n170 because it's really the first
study that kind of talked about the n170
was in 1996 one of my favorite studies
of all time by a guy named Schlomo
benton who i believe actually did a
postdoc here at yale earlier in his
career and he found that when you show
people lots of different kinds of things
you got this negative spike and 170
milliseconds that was largest and
fastest two phases it was a really
robust finding and what was so
interesting about this to people because
people this had been looked at in other
ways but what was really interesting was
to see that this happened so fast that
170 milliseconds after seeing a face
your brain is treating that differently
from everything else and so that was
kind of news so now since then there
have been many many many studies looking
at the n170
all kinds of manipulations what happens
when you turn faces upside down what
happens when you do a photographic
inversion of a face so it looks like a
photo negative what does the n170 look
like in little kids what does it look
like people with autism what does it
look like in people with schizophrenia
so there's been many many studies of the
n170 some of the basic things to know
about it
are that it represents the earliest
stages of face processing maybe not the
earliest stage there's some evidence
that activity at 100 milliseconds might
also individuate faces from other things
or distinguished faces from other kinds
of visual stimuli we think that it
represents structural encoding so this
is the stage of face perception in which
your brain registers a face as a face so
not this is my mother or this is my best
friend or this is my neighbor but just
this is a face
the n170 is sensitive to inversion well
this is kind of neat remember we talked
about processing strategies and what
happens when we turn a face upside down
easier or harder to recognize I'm gonna
keep you all awake harder to recognize
so we we might think so if you were
gonna make a guess about what would
happen to a face specific input so we
turn faces upside down we stop treating
like faces we turn faces upside down
what should happen to a face specific
ERP component should go away right we
should we would we wouldn't treat it as
a face the exact opposite it actually
gets bigger and it gets slower and so
that's called the inversion effect and
so I mentioned that we can study erps
and very young children and people have
looked at face perception in very young
children so by 3 months we see specific
activity elicited by faces it happens
later so it's kind of a common
amalgamation of activity distributed
between an n to 90 and a P 400 and then
over time those seem to sneer together
both get faster and we have the adult
like patterns by the time a person is
around 14 years old so this is a face
specific component or I should say face
sensitive component but we can also just
look at other brain components and put
faces into a paradigm and which other
things could be so we could look at
recognition memory for faces we could
look at affective salience for faces and
I'll talk about all those different
kinds of things in some and some of the
ERP studies of autism that I'm going to
talk about so let's move on and talk a
little bit more about autism what do we
know about faces in autism and I'm going
to make a disclaimer right at the start
faces are now one of the most well
studied one of the most well studied
areas of research and autism and I guess
well study well study gives an
inappropriate connotation because welds
well studied seems to suggest that that
they're well understood and it's the
exact opposite
there's been so much research and faces
but the research has really painted a
confusing picture and so I'm going to
give you a story that can fit
one class today but but it's a more
nuanced story and I'll actually tell you
about some of the work that we're doing
to shed light on those nuances at the
very end of my lecture because that's
one of our our our labs goals now is to
try to understand well why do some
studies find certain problems with faces
and other studies don't why why do we
see this heterogeneity in face
perception in autism and it's worth
mention it's worth mentioning one of dr.
Clinton's first slides showed the idea
of an autism spectrum right so there
were lots of people all different colors
under a rainbow it looked like some kind
of happy autism party was it if we think
about where we diagnosed autism right
there's a list of twelve symptoms
how many symptoms do you need to get a
diagnosis of autism not even autism
spectrum disorder autism the most of
your diagnosis on the spectrum does
anybody know six six so six of twelve so
you could theoretically have two
children diagnosed with autism with
non-overlapping symptoms so it makes
apps to me absolutely perfect sense that
we would have heterogeneity in research
studies people with autism so one of the
really most robust findings in autism
both clinically and I'm sure many of you
have noticed this now in your practicum
places if the people with autism seemed
to approach faces in a different way
before we had these really elegant
studies that we have now where we're
taking infants who are at risk for
autism by virtue of having an older
sibling with autism and studying the
development of the disorder in a
prospective way we used to study in
retrospective ways so one way to study
things retrospectively is using
videotapes and so my graduate advisor
Geraldine Dawson and a person who is a
graduate student at the time Julie
österlen has this idea to look at first
birthday parties so it's a nice
experiment right well what we want an
experiment we want things to be well
controlled standardized the same for
everybody and we can't really do that
with home videos but for birthday
parties the same kinds of things happen
in every birthday party so we have a
nice comparison to see how infants might
be different and also we're interested
in things like social referencing
so social referencing is the idea that
you look to another person's face to
figure out what to make sense of some
what how to make sense of something
novel and so what better situation to
elicit social referencing and a
one-year-old child then for the first
time in their life to take out a piece
of dessert put it in front of them and
then set it on fire
right most kids have never had parents
set their their high chair on fire
before and so it's a nice chance for
students for kids try to figure out is
this something good something bad and so
what they did is they looked at these
home videos and they found that first
birthdays and then in subsequent studies
even earlier by six months kids who
would go on to be diagnosed with autism
look different from kids who went on to
develop typically and also kids who went
on to have non-autistic developmental
delays we know that throughout the
lifespan people with autism have more
trouble with recognizing faces with
interpreting emotional expressions with
maintaining eye gaze there's really
striking i've encountered striking
anecdotal examples a fellow i worked
with at the university of washington was
a man with high-functioning autism and
his interest his preoccupation was food
choices and so in the halls of the
building he would approach me and say
Jamie do you do you like apple pie or do
you like pumpkin pie and then I would
say I like I like both and he said well
you do you like them or do you love him
and he would kind of asked a series of
questions to really get at your your
food preferences but when I would see
him outside of work I'd walk past him on
the street he wouldn't recognize me he
wouldn't say anything but then if I said
hey how are you doing he would say do
you like apples or do you love them and
so here he needed the context and my
voice to recognize me we also see
different processing strategies for
faces in autism we see a reduced
inversion effect so they don't have the
same decrement in performance when we
turn faces upside down we don't see the
same decomposition effect in fact some
studies have shown that they're better
at feature based matching especially if
it revolves around the mouth
and so we infer that people with autism
aren't using this configural processing
strategy that we've talked about there
are approaching phases in a piecemeal
way the way most of us approach objects
you've heard someone speak much more
eloquently than I would be able to about
this already but dr. Clinton and Warren
Jones and others have looked at the way
people with autism look at faces and
look at social information and we know
that people with autism look less at the
eyes they look more mouths and things
when there's three people interacting on
screen they have a harder time tracking
those interactions and they they fail to
follow attentional cues things like a
person pointing their finger on screen
from fMRI research that actually
happened here Bob Schultz another close
colleague who has since moved on to
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia to
start the Center for autism research
there to produce another seminal paper
the Child Study Center looking at this
activity in the fusiform face area so we
talked about how Marvin Chan and seek in
with canvas sure found this hot spot in
the brain for faces well Bob looked at
people with autism and saw how their
brains activated two faces and he saw
that this activity was was reduced in
people with autism
despite activity to objects looking very
similar so now let's talk a little bit
about ERP studies a face related brain
function in autism so we're going to
talk about three different areas so face
recognition emotion recognition and
structural encoding and so first I'm
going to talk about face recognition and
this is work that we did at the
University of Washington as part of a
study of early development of children
with autism we did this work in
three-year-olds and this was actually
based very closely on a paradigm used in
typical development a paradigm created
by Chuck Nelson and so we did is we
showed children familiar and unfamiliar
faces and this is the slide where some
day when my daughters are old enough to
log on to YouTube they can still think
that I'm a jerk but at least then though
I wasn't a hypocrite so we we showed
them familiar
and unfamiliar faces and familiar and
unfamiliar toys and we contrasted brain
activities so what's different in a face
and a toy in terms of think about the
developmental paths I talked about
earlier which path is for faces the
social path or the non social path which
path is for toys the less social path
and so we have a nice kind of a nice
design where we can look at familiarity
for social information and familiar
familiarity for non social information
and we have a reason to to have certain
predictions based on typical development
we thought that in typical development
we would see different differential
activity too familiar versus unfamiliar
faces and objects because that's what
we'd seen before we look at people with
autism we saw something different so
these are very young kids these are
three-year-olds so I was there and we
collected the data it's I cast a rosy
picture about the applicability of ERP
for studying arranged developmental
functional levels and a range of Ages in
autism but it's still really an
adventure to try to do an ERP experiment
with a three-year-old person with autism
who doesn't have any language involves
lots of energy lots of toys and lots of
MMS and so what we saw is if we look at
objects and these are both waveforms for
people for the young children with
autism we saw this component the p400
it's called and it's associated with a
recognition so we saw an enhancement to
novel objects and relative to familiar
objects now these are faces so we the
same see the same kind of peak but
what's different in the faces and the
objects
right and so we saw that when we look at
the non social information they look
just like their typical counterparts for
the faces they did they weren't showing
differential brain activity and so when
this study came out one of the concerns
was that we were saying that kids with
autism don't recognize their mother
which isn't the case at all I was there
I was running these kids they they knew
their mothers and they often ran to them
frantically when we tried to do the erps
with them they certainly recognize their
mothers but it's telling us they're
using different mechanisms to do that
and that's one of the things I think is
really important for us to learn about
autism what are the compensatory
mechanisms so in another aspect of
social information processing that we've
used ERP to study and very young
children with autism these are the same
group of three-year-olds is emotion
recognition and so for this study we
contrasted their brain responses to
neutral versus fearful faces and fear is
a really useful emotion to use because
fear is closely linked to the function
in the amygdala which is which is one of
the social brain regions involved in
autism and how do you get a what an 8
month old child to show fear you show
her her older sister coming at her with
one more sticker that she's about to put
on her face so we show these
three-year-olds neutral and fearful
faces and to be clear we did not show
them neutral and fearful faces of my
daughter's these were from a
standardized series of faces developed
the Ekman series they're called but we
can't show them for the purposes of this
lecture and again so this is the
different ERP component this is again
it's not a face specific component it's
just kind of associated with salience
it's called the negative slow-wave and
in the typical kids we saw a big
difference between the fearful face and
the neutral face but what did we see in
the kids with autism
difference or no difference no
difference and so one of the nice things
about this study is that er peas are
kind of abstract right we do them in the
lab we can make guesses about how
looking at pictures of emotional faces
versus neutral faces maps onto things
that happen in real life but it's kind
of a stretch so what we did in this
study is we also did this kind of
response to the stress tasks were
graduate students like myself played
with the kids we sat at a table is
videotaped and we had this hammering toy
and so we would play with this hammering
toy and we would pretend to hit our
finger with a hammer and then we would
pretend to cry and then we would just
cry for like a minute and the video and
then after we look at the videotapes and
determine what the kid did did the kid
just think oh great you know this guy
stopped playing with a hammer now it's
my turn or would the kid look sad would
the kid pay attention to me at all
and this is one of the times when I
regret that we can't show the picture
because we have this a great picture
from that study where I'm saying they're
crying and a little three-year-old boy
with ups it was hammering away but his
mother is looking at me but it's not an
empathetic look it's a look like what is
wrong with you so and what we found was
actually so if we if we wanted to make a
jump about how sensitivity neural
sensitivity to expressions of to
emotional expressions would map on to
behavior we might think about these
things being connected that's exactly
what we saw so a different component the
n300 it's latency how long it took to
happen was associated with the amount of
time these children spent attending to
famed distress so looking now some
different work this was again work done
at the University of Washington and this
has work done in adolescents and adults
with autism we took that study done by
Shulman bent in that classic 1996 one
and looked at the n170 in people with
autism we showed them upright and
inverted faces and so I described the
n170 but I hadn't shown you one so this
is an example of an n170 this is from 14
typical
typical adolescents and adults and what
we see is that negative dip in
electrical activity that happens around
170 milliseconds and this is associated
with phases and when we showed these
same faces to the people with autism
we saw a different kind of response they
did it wasn't like I didn't have an n1
70 but it was different from the typical
counterparts and I should make clear
that these people were just as smart as
difficult counterparts they performed
similarly on many non social behavioral
measures but they had a very different
response and their response was actually
something them can only pick up with ERP
there's their response was to be slower
so while most people have in one
seventies run and around 170 180
milliseconds the people with autism were
much slower and we also looked at this
inversion effect so if we show them the
faces upside down would we see a
different different response and so this
is the what an inversion effect looks
like in typical people so you see a big
the red line is upside down faces the
blue line is the upright faces and so
what you see is a bigger slower response
to upside-down faces and in the kids
with autism and the adolescents and
adults with autism rather we saw a
slightly different response so we did
see a little difference in amplitude but
was really salient was again the timing
so whereas typical people slowed down
when they saw an upside down face people
thought to them there wasn't any
difference there in terms of timing
their upright faces were equivalent to
their inverted faces and that's shown by
the the slope of these purple lines they
are those those purple lines are the
inversion effect so what we saw in these
adolescents and adults were slower
processing speed and insensitivity to
inversion and excusing again we wanted
to see if we could tie this to something
some kind of behavioral measure that we
could be sure was more ecologically
valid or we could be optimistic was
ecologically valid and what we saw we
administered a standardized test a face
recognition it's part of a memory scale
called the Wechsler memory scale
and we looked at how good people were at
recognizing faces and so again despite
being comparably intelligent people with
autism made twice as many mistakes on a
face recognition task and moreover these
mistakes correlated with their
processing speed so how fast the person
showed this spike to a face was actually
associate with how good they were at
face recognition so this was actually
the first study to look at the n170 in
autism but since then there have been
many studies and what has emerged is
that we see that across a number of
studies there's delayed latency for
faces this has been found in children as
young as 3 years of age what's very
interesting is that the same effect has
been found in parents of children with
autism and in a very recent study by my
colleague Joe McCleary in the UK he
spent in ten month olds who are at risk
for autism but haven't been diagnosed
we've replicated in other studies the
intensity to the inversion and in the
other forms of a typicality some studies
have found decreased amplitude some have
found abnormal lateralization or
patterns of activity the scalp that are
more characteristic of younger children
and again as I said before not all of
these results are replicated across all
studies it's really a heterogeneous
picture and I'll talk about some
manipulations that we're doing now some
experimental manipulations to understand
more about why we see some effects and
some kids and different effects and
other kids
well let me let me go on to the next
part and see if I don't think that faces
our process like objects I think that
faces may not be processed in a special
way by people else but it actually turns
out that objects can also be processed
in a very special way which I'll talk
about right now
so what do we make of this do we think
that people with autism are just born
with a hole in their brain in the face
processing regions do we think that
they're just unable to do this kind of
information processing in their brain no
we kind of explained it in a
developmental way so we know that faces
are processed in special ways we know
that the specialization associated with
face processing happens over time so
what if people with autism come into the
world less drawn to other people and
therefore they fail to pay attention to
people they fail to become face experts
so if we think about our path towards
social expertise culminating in face
expertise we could think about people
with autism failing to chart that course
and so we publish as we called the
social motivation hypothesis and the
idea is the problem in autism is really
decreased social motivation which leads
to inattention to faces which leads to a
failure to develop expertise and then
that's reflected in the atypical
specialization we see both in terms of
brain and behavior but there's an
important presumption here and this is
something that's been very interesting
to me that I've studied over the past
couple of years here at Yale is is this
piece I started off today talking about
how we have different explanations for
autism and it it might be a social
problem but social information could
also be a red herring maybe it's a
problem with complex information
processing and we know that the
development of expertise is something
that requires complex information
processing so what if people with autism
just have a problem developing
perceptual expertise so how can we look
at that and what is perceptual expertise
so when we talk about perceptual
expertise it's the idea that as we
become really good
when we get a lot of experience
distinguishing among things that are
very similar like faces or if you were a
monkey expert like monkeys we start to
treat them different so we start to
treat the faces we start to treat those
objects or those non face things the way
we treat faces we start to see signs of
holistic processing we start to see
inversion effects we start to see
activity and peace form gyrus and most
relevant to us we start to see enhanced
n170 amplitude one thing that hasn't
been studied yet what is isn't well
understood yet is to what piece your
affective experience plays in so I have
there an example of a car and a bird and
those are both things that have been
studied in neuroscience research to show
expertise affects what a person gets
really good at individuating among birds
or different kinds of cars they get a
bigger n170 than people who don't care
about them but what hasn't but what we
don't know is it's rare that a person
develops some kind of expertise without
some kind of personal interest so car
experts aren't just car experts in the
way you know like if you think about a
baggage handler they see lots of bags
but they probably feel differently about
bags and car experts feeling about cars
right and so that's something that isn't
studied I think it's relevant to
studying perceptual expertise in autism
because the two ways that people have
gone about it so far are to either train
people with autism to be expert in
something or to look at something
they're expert in already so the
training studies teach a person to
become expert in a particular area
what's nice about this is it makes for a
very clean elegant experience experiment
because you have a group of people then
who have all comparable degrees of
expertise you've controlled their access
to it you know but what the problems
with it is that it's not really the way
we develop expertise in real life so
there's not intrinsic interest and
there's not much effective involvement
we would assume no naturalistic studies
solve those problems people become
experts in things because they're
interested in them
many people with autism really become
experts in things the problem is is that
it's hard to find groups of children who
are all expert in the same thing so that
we can do a clean experiment so this is
a problem that we had kind of thought
about quite a bit one of the nice things
about being a clinician is that
sometimes you don't have to have good
ideas good ideas gonna walk into your
clinic and so one day I was working with
a kid a four year old boy who was very
bright we'd followed him since he was
two I'm talking about this this is my
favorite video to show but again we
can't show it so we'll do a little
reenactment but we were doing a play
session and he would he would say things
differently he would see things very
differently than I would so you are
unfortunate to be sitting right up front
so you can be you're gonna be the boy so
what's in this bag I was I was afraid
that was going to happen
the these are foam blocks we'll try a
different one no you I got it wrong okay
what what do you see there can you tell
me anything else about it okay so these
are these are pieces of actually a
diagnostic assessment that we use called
the 8 oz and whenever I would bring out
the boy would see as a letter so the boy
and one of my students saw these as w's
to me they were just blocks when I
brought this out I said oh look there's
a guy snorkeling and he said yeah the
snorkel is a J when I brought this out I
didn't even realize what was happening I
brought paths fast his face very quickly
he said WPS as a WPS and I looked Oh
Western Psychological Services the
company that makes it so this boy was
seeing letters everywhere and it
actually turns out it's a pretty common
area of expertise in autism so many
young children autism get very
interested in letters we're not exactly
sure why we think that because letters
are omnipresent and there
nice because they're always the same 26
and they're always in the same sequence
so they they kind of fit fit the rules
for a person who likes ritual and
routine we find it's an area of strength
for people on the spectrum even though
problems with language is a really
salient part of autism we see intact
word reading and decoding and most
children with autism or at least what
would be predicted by their intellectual
level and then there's a subgroup of
children who have what we call
hyperlexia we're really precocious
self-taught readers and that's a five to
fifteen percent prevalence and a lot of
the really good work in hyperlexia has
been done right here by Alena grigorenko
and Tina Newman out of Naples so we've
got an area in which many people have
autism develop expertise but it's only
good to us as people who are interests
in the brain if it gives us a way to
measure production per sepcial expertise
in terms of brain function and it turns
out it does so a colleague Alan Wong who
at the time was a graduate student with
Isabel Kathina vanderbolten is now at
the university of hong kong looked at
how people learn to process letters and
he did a very nice experiment where he
took letters in the Roman alphabet which
is what we read you know what you're
seeing here then he took Chinese letters
and then he made up an alphabet and he
showed these letters to people and
measured their brain response and what
he found was that you got an enhanced
n170 if you could read the letters of an
alphabet didn't matter which alphabet so
if you were bilingual reading Chinese in
English you get a bigger n170 to both
Chinese characters and Roman characters
if you're a person who could only read
English then you'd get bigger and when
72 Roman characters but not to Chinese
or soo Devon they were equivalent so
what this lets us do then is kind of map
out those endpoints so if we think about
our social expertise path ending in
phases we could take a look
experimentally at a non-social expertise
path ending in letters and so we can
track things that we think we're a
social experts in versus not experts in
with houses and then pseudo letters and
this is some of the recent work that
we've done in people with autism and so
we've compared is expert and then non
expert stimuli in the social domain
faces versus houses and in the non
social domain letters versus social
letter versus pseudo letters and then we
do is we take the n170 we record it from
this is a 256 electrode net and we
record the n170 from patches on the
right and left hemisphere and so for
faces
we saw the kinds of things that we've
seen before this was a younger group of
children that I've studied before but we
found that on a test of face recognition
they performed significantly worse than
their typical counterparts despite being
as as generally intelligent as them and
we saw in the right hemisphere the
hemisphere that's most often associated
with face perception we saw that they
had a slower latency just two faces than
typical individuals and we look at
houses both groups were equivalent I
talked earlier about source localization
and we're starting to dabble in it
although we're not necessarily zealots
but for both groups we saw that the n170
localized to the fusiform gyrus so it's
not like there's really qualitatively
different kinds of things happening in
the brains it's just happening in a
different pace but what was really
intricate interesting to us was letters
so first we looked at at behavior we
looked at reading in two different ways
so we can look at reading words reading
words can happen in in with different
kinds of strategies you might recognize
them based on the shape of the word we
might sign the sound them out but we can
force a person to sound them out testing
their mastery of all the the individual
pieces of the word if we make up words
so if we use words that nobody's ever
seen before the only way you could
pronounce it correctly is you understand
the rules of sounding out words and on
both kinds of measures people with
autism scored just like their typical
counterparts and both groups scored in
the average range so we know because
this is a normal test that it's not
something idiosyncratic about people who
live in New Haven they're performing
just as well as anybody in their age
range would
the country we look at the n170 the
first question really was would we see
an enhanced n 172 letters even in the
typical adolescents and children
adolescence because it hadn't really
been looked at in a roof this young
before and that is what we saw so the
pink highlights the n170 and you see the
purple line is letters the green line is
the pseudo letters and we see a larger
amplitude two letters and when we see in
the group with autism we did we actually
saw a bigger difference between letters
and pseudo letters in the group with
autism so when we when we compared the
groups both groups showed and enhanced
amplitude two letters there was no
differences between the groups
the typical group showed that the
expected pattern of left lateralized
responds but the group with autism
showed bilateral specialization you can
really see it here so this is a picture
kind of a think of it as a heat map and
the darker the purple color shows the
more negative the activity and so we
found is the typical group we see things
localized to the left and the autism
group actually recruited right
hemisphere regions which is kind of
interesting because those are the
regions typically involved in face
perception so we see in this experiment
we see that they have impaired face
recognition atypical neural response to
faces they show intact word reading and
preserved kind of enhanced the neuro
response to letters with recruitment of
the right hemisphere so what does this
tell us about autism well it makes the
case that their brains their brains can
learn none of us are born learning to
read I'm pretty sure with yell students
anybody could you guys could and I'm
pretty sure you couldn't so we know that
these are things that they've learned
over the course of development we know
that to learn these things is kind of a
complicated brain operation it requires
your prefrontal cortex to be computing
communicate with cortical regions way in
the back so we know that the things like
this can work in the brain it tells us
we need a more nuanced story so we need
to look at connectivity within specific
rather than just generic dysfunction and
this also gives us encouragement that
all these different kinds of
interventions that we do aiming to
improve social information processing by
driving people with autism to attend to
these things may pay off so now I want
to talk about this is a this is all the
more cutting-edge stuff so this is stuff
that that isn't published hasn't been
talked about before these are some of
the things that we're working on now
so I've alluded to this earlier but one
of the one of the things we're very
interested in understanding now is why
what accounts for the heterogeneity in
autism especially in terms of faces so
why do we see some kids showing delayed
responding and other kids not showing
delayed responses across studies and
there's different kinds of ideas that
have been put forward to explain it one
involves visual attention and this is
pretty straight forward if people with
autism are always looking at different
parts of the face then typically
developing people we're gonna expect
different patterns of brain activity so
we could look at how visual attention
maps on to face perception another piece
is social motivation and this was a neat
interaction for me this was a group of
parents actually were here at the Child
Study Center and I gave a talk similar
to this and I I showed our model as a
suitable social motivation hypothesis
and the guy came up to me afterwards and
he said Jamie well you just said doesn't
make any sense
my son has autism but he is super
socially motivated he has spent his
whole life
getting in people's faces trying to
interact with him and he has a really
odd awkward and often unsuccessful
approach but he's very motivated and
it's a very good point right in 1979
Lorna wing talked about different groups
of children who who were active but odd
versus passive versus aloof and we
really don't have a sense of how those
kinds of differences within the very
diverse group of people that we would
call people with autism maps on
differences in brain activity and then
finally the third potential explanation
is looking at
connectivity within these face
perception systems or dysfunction in
individual components because we've
really talked today about face
processing as a thing but it's not it's
really the collection of a lot of
individual things that happen in the
brain so I'm going to now show you some
preliminary data that we've that we're
using to start to look at these things
so in terms of visual attention what
we've done and this is with a graduate
student who was here last year who's now
getting her PhD at the Institute of
Psychiatry in the UK Celeste Chung and
we've well if you want to know how
looking at different parts of the face
could affect the neural response what
kind of experiment could you do what
could you do
sure you could do that and that's
actually been done the very first n170
paper showed different chunks of faces
different pieces but the problem is
you're you're changing the face we've
just shown the eyes well one thing you
could do is force them to look at
different parts of the faces right so
you could have a crosshair on the screen
that makes them look at the eyes or
makes them look at the nose or makes
them look at the mouth this is what
we've actually been doing and this is in
typical adults and the idea is that
maybe people with autism are showing
different brain activity because they
tend to look at the mouths
rather than the eyes and indeed we
expected that when we forced people to
look at the eyes we'd get stronger brain
activity a stronger n170
then if we force them to look anywhere
else but that's actually not what we're
finding we're finding that whether you
look at the eyes or whether you look at
the mouth you get a bigger n170
then if you look at the center of the
face or if there's no crosshair at all
so it's almost like looking at
information rich parts of the face
elicited a bigger n170 than just the
eyes in isolation the eyes actually
elicit a bigger n170 so we're now
starting to do this paradigm on people
with autism and the question will be is
when we compare people with autism and
typically developing peers controlling
for where they're looking are we still
gonna find these same kinds of brain
differences or is it really explained
away by by where they look and hopefully
next week Kevin Palfrey will talk to you
about some of the really neat fMRI work
but he's done showing that when you
control when you manipulate a person's
scan path in the magnet you can make
typical people look like they have the
brain activity of a person with autism
and vice versa so the other piece is
social motivation so we're we haven't
yet started tease apart groups of people
with autism with social who are
motivated for social interaction who are
who are more aloof but we're actually
looking at in the typical population
because if you think about it we all
very right the people in this room who
are gonna spend Friday night and you
know and some party talking lots of
people and there's good people in this
room Hoover has been Friday night in a
library I'm assuming you all are gonna
be Friday night in the library reading
about autism but I know that's not true
right and so you might say that the
people who are at the party or
extroverts and the people who are at the
library
introverts and so actually what we've
done is we've brought we've screamed
people to be really extreme introverts
or extreme extroverts
and we've brought them in for ERPs and
we've really been surprised at what we
found
really striking differences in brain
activity and these are all people these
aren't people with autism these are
people out and about but if you look in
blue are extroverts and if you look at
red are introverts and again this is
work done by Celeste chunk you see that
the extroverts have bigger n170 s and
really what's also salient is extroverts
show an inversion effect and introverts
don't so this is very much in line with
the idea that social motivation shapes
our brain activity and we could think
about it in developmental way or we
could also think about it in terms of a
salience way maybe social information is
just more salient in the moment for
extroverts and then now is uh it's a
this is a big slide so I'll get you
ready for it the idea that face
perception I've talked about the n170
but the n170 represents one stage in a
series of stages of fate of the face
processing system and so what we can do
because the temporal acuity of ERP we
can tease it apart so this is kind of a
mock-up of a theoretical a possible
explanation of the way face processing
works in the brain so if we think about
a component called the P 100 showing us
basic visual processing the n170 showing
a structural encoding and then things
like the N 250
showing us higher-order face processing
like effect recognition and or identity
recognition we can think about how those
things tie in to the mirror neuron
system and then we can think about how
those things tie in to related behaviors
like imitation or face perception and
then how those things influenced by how
it influenced social interaction and we
have ways of measuring social
interaction real-life and so we've
actually just submitted this as a grant
actually today a grant went in to do a
study with colleagues at University of
Washington to look at just this to use
ERP to brake face processing into
individual components and then see well
if we're finding that some people aren't
some people have delays in the n170 and
other people don't maybe if we look at
the broader array of neural functions
associated with face perception and
beyond we're gonna start to see
different profiles so maybe they're slow
and 170 years who compensate with fast
and 250 s and actually look ok here or
maybe they're slow and 170 people who
have even slower and 250 s and have
really big problems here but with with
statistical approaches like structural
equation modeling we can actually test
the directionality of these arrows and
look in a Pyrrhic 'el way which models
best fit different groups of people so
we can compare for sure people with
autism and typical people but even more
interestingly we can then try to tease
apart different groups of people within
the category of autism and this I should
say this is developed with my colleague
Rafael Bernier at the University of
Washington and then the next step is
this is work that we're not doing yet
but is imminent we're gonna take
advantage of the applicability of ERP to
babies and we're gonna start doing ERPs
on little babies who are at risk for
autism to try to track the development
of social behavior in a prospective way
and we're also going to try to do we're
already doing in adults is try to get
around that problem of what people are
looking at by recording ERP and eye
tracking at the same time so with dr.
Clinton and Warren Jones we're working
on systems so that they have as you've
seen really elegant ways of eye tracking
in infants and so we can record their
brain activity and what they're looking
at at the same time and the idea is to
kind of really do a broad abroad broad
measures across domains of perceptions
so looking at visual information by
comparing faces and toys looking at
auditory information by comparing voices
and then as Amy and Warren are inclined
to do using more naturalistic stimuli so
samples of mothers and other people
talking and object moving to music and
examining in real-time the brain
responds to that so I want to quickly
acknowledge all the people who have
helped with this research most
importantly the children with autism and
their families who come in and and
tolerate all the things that we ask them
to do in the hope that we're gonna help
future generations of chilled with
autism many colleagues here at Yale
colleagues in other places and to Nora
and Agnes who although they didn't have
a say in the matter
we'll have retrospectively permitted me
to to plaster their face all over the
Internet thank you